my name is Gabriela van aken and I'm a
senior biochemistry major here at
Hillsdale I'm honored to introduce our
speaker for today dr. Arthur Herman dr.
Herman is a senior fellow at the Hudson
Institute and director of its quantum
alliance initiative where he works on
quantum computing and related quantum
information technology he received his
PhD in history from the John Hopkins
University dr. Herman has been a
professor of history at Georgetown
University Catholic University George
Mason Mason University and the
University of the South he writes
regularly for commentary foreign policy
the American interest mosaic nagae asian
review in The Wall Street Journal he is
the author of several books including
Gandhi in Churchill the epic rivalry
that destroyed an empire and forged our
age which was a finalist for the
Pulitzer Prize in 2009 1917 Lennon
Wilson and the birth of the New World
Disorder and Douglas MacArthur American
warrior please join me in welcoming dr.
Arthur Herman
[Applause]
well thank you very much for a very
sweet introduction and hi how are you
it's been a great been a great session
don't you think the lectures have been
great the lecturers have been wonderful
the food and the drink has been
excellent
and it has been I think a really
wonderful tour of America's leading
military heroes and I know that we're
all of us very very grateful that Allen
gelser was able to finish his speech
from last night he gave us a bit of a
scare there my friend
last night but it's really great to have
Allen back with us and an up and
operating what I'm gonna be doing and
what's gonna happen today and tonight is
we are now going to nudge you none too
gently into the 20th century into the
violence century the most violent
century probably in human history and
we'll be talking about two figures I
will be talking about one and then
Victor Davis Hanson will be talking
about another who who spring out of that
century and out of the conflicts that
are involved it but I think what you'll
see and I will certainly say this for
the person I'll be talking about this
MacArthur as he will definitely see
traces of that earlier century of a more
courteous age of an age which placed
values on things such as honor courage
dedication to duty and dedication to
country and God that reflect that
earlier owes earlier traditions in ways
that are really quite striking and it's
great amazing to think about so I'm
going to talk about Douglas MacArthur
the subject of my 2016 book and what I
want to do is to give you to start out
with understanding just
eh should we say a quick overview of his
biography and of the remarkable man that
he was but as always when we're talking
about the character of any person of any
man the place to start is with the
father and you're not gonna understand
Douglas MacArthur the man unless you
understand
Arthur MacArthur the father here he is
you know every time I see this picture
of him and his lieutenants uniform yet
first you think like it's a it's a kid
dressed up for military what happened
they're back again you think it's a kid
dressed up for Halloween costume or for
costume ball and that is until you look
into the eyes and to the mouth of the
man it's standing there there's sixteen
year old here who has enlisted in the
24th Wisconsin regiment and who quickly
rises from basically an adjutant role to
finally finally by the end of by the end
of his end of his service during the
Civil War to full colonel it's a service
which earns him to serious wounds earns
him the Medal of Honor at the siege of
Chattanooga with the taking of Luke
Lookout Mountain in which he leads his
regiment the 24th Wisconsin up the
mountain leading carrying his his
regimental flag and it said that what he
said what he cried out as leading his
troops up on Wisconsin became the state
motto and I know there's some of you
here from Wisconsin so that's definitely
information that you're going to want to
write down and take note of but a man
who's whose bravery under fire whose
skill and command and whose leadership
in battle was such that by the end of
the war he had risen to fertile colonel
even though he was still not old enough
to vote
against all family advice he decided to
remain in the Army at the war's end even
as the nation demobilized in the number
of position and posts in which to serve
in the US Army drastically diminished so
we ended up taking himself and his
family his wife who's nicknamed he was
actually a southern lady a kind of
real-life version of Scarlett O'Hara in
many ways who became was became known as
by her family nickname of pinky it would
be very important to the formation why
does this keep bumping up one slide more
that's not what I want there it's not oh
there we go
the the was oh yeah talking about the
family aunt to a series of remote army
outposts in fact the life that you see
of your average US Army cavalry or
infantry captain on the frontier in the
John Ford movies that was Arthur
MacArthur's life that was the life he
led in the 1870s and 1880s it's the life
into which Douglas MacArthur was born in
an army barracks in an Arkansas and the
life that he would dedicate himself to
for the rest of his and until the very
end of his life here because he very
quickly followed in his father's
footsteps his revered father's footsteps
into the army he would go to West Point
where he was heavily involved in both
athletics and academics we see him here
as manager of the Harvard football team
that's him why does it do that guys I
don't want to move it I don't want I
want to stay at the one slide till I'm
ready to go if there's a way to fix that
it'd be great
even better
do we lose it all together or are we
coming back anyway it's time it Harv at
the West Point was such that he was
without doubt the most accomplished
graduate of West Point
since Robert Ely the academic records
that he scored would stand as records
for for years and decades to come in the
course of that then when we get our
pictures back what we'll do is we'll see
him as he makes his move into into into
active service during the First World
War and it's during that active service
that he'll will be he'll be awarded no
less than seven silver stars in action
in combat there and will rise to the
rank of Brigadier General the youngest
Brigadier General in the US Army and
eventually even - major - Major General
in spite of a long-standing record of
insubordination and disobedience to
orders to superiors which he establishes
first during the First World War and
then goes on to become part of his
pattern of life going on we could talk
more about that a little bit then after
after World War one he goes on to he's
been asked he's asked to take over his
alma mater West Point where he becomes
the youngest superintendent of West
Point in in its history and carries out
a series of reforms of the curriculum to
update the institution from its
nineteenth-century roots and from a
curriculum that robert e lee or ulysses
s grant would have recognized - one that
it's now going to include a miaar
recruit more there he is getting getting
his Distinguished Service Cross from
General Pershing they didn't get along
there was there were constant conflicts
between them he was Pershing was also
competing for the affections of the
woman
that MacArthur would eventually marry
that added an extra shall we say juicy
dimension to the rivalry between the two
men but even pursing for all of his
dislike for what he saw as MacArthur's
arrogance for his his his affected heirs
for his inability it seems to
straightforwardly follow orders that he
were given had to admit he was a
first-rate officer and a first-rate
commander and one of the bravest men men
he ever met a a testimony by the way
which he shared with General George
Patton when Patton got to know him in
the First World War and summoned or saw
him under action wrote back to his
family and said this is the bravest man
I've ever seen in my life Douglas
MacArthur so there is a superintendent
at West Point then after that goes on to
a series of other military posts and
takes off time in 1928 to become
president of the Olympic Committee and
takes the American Olympic team to the
Olympic Games in the Netherlands this
was a landmark event in the history of
the Olympics by the way because it
really was Douglas MacArthur who created
the modern American Olympic Committee
and effort in it he was determined that
in the course of what was going to have
what happened in those games of the
United States would come out ahead and
take the lead in it and so he took a
personal interest in everything that I'm
happening unfolded in the course of the
games his motto that he gave to his
coaches and to the participants all the
way through as Americans never quit this
is this is a show of who we are what
happens in the Olympic Games and how
many medals we carried away and in fact
they carried away a record number of
medals 24 of them more in fact gold
medals more gold medals than the next
two countries combined Germany and
Finland they set 17 Olympic records at
the 1928 games American athletes did and
7 World Records and American Olympic
effort would never be the same again
he set a standard
standard for what American Olympic
performance at American sports in
general would have to achieve that that
there was embodied in American sports an
aspect of American character that was
expressed through winning and through
competing at the highest possible level
it's one of the aspects of Douglas
MacArthur that he brings to the that he
brings to the cultural table of the
United States as well as to his military
career then comes up outbreak in World
War two when he is in the Philippines
commanding US forces there after being
bottle necked there by the surprise
Japanese attack and making a dramatic
escape from Corregidor to Australia to
regroup and to rearm the United States
to take back to Philippines and the
other parts of the southwest Pacific
Theatre in which he's engaged in he
manages in 1944 to fulfill his promise
that he made to the Filipinos before he
left Corregidor I shall return and he
does return in October 1944 with the
dramatic landing at layette Leyte near
Tacloban on the eastern coast and he
makes this dramatic radio announcement
to the citizens of the Philippines that
he has returned and that a time has come
for them to rally against their Japanese
occupiers and that freedom has finally
come the 4000 mile trek of return back
to the Philippines and then to push on
to Japan is complete then after Japan's
surrender he will all again participate
in one of the major events of the
starting points of the post-war world
when he arrives at Atsugi Airport in
order to receive the Japanese surrender
and this moment became one of the most
important really for the development of
the American occupation in Japan and the
entire post-war period because as you
can see as MacArthur descends down the
staircase here from the plane from his
private plane which the baton which he
had arrived from
arrived from the Philippines he arrived
unarmed carrying no sidearms and
insisted that everyone in his party
carried no sidearms this was at a time
when there was still enormous fear about
Japanese snipers at large in the country
he was even warned not to land at Atsugi
at all without a massive armed escort
they said do you realize there is a
training camp for Banzai pilots here at
Atsugi we've got we've got 8,000 Banzai
pilots here who are just waiting for a
chance to get their hands on you if they
possibly can you're crazy to come here
they're crazy at least not to come
without a without a massive military
escort and the prosody said no we're
gonna go do it we're gonna go unarmed in
the process it was part of the step part
of the psychological operation that the
McArthur was engaged in in post-war
Japan to make the Japanese realize that
the United States were there not as
occupiers but his partners in building a
new Japan and a new partnership in Asia
which was of course very much reflected
also in the major ceremony which took
place at the signing of the surrender
terms for Japan and for the Allied
nations which MacArthur presided over
and announced over the over worldwide
hook-up on radio and when the signing of
the treaty was was completed MacArthur
was able to announce that the that the
that the hostilities have ceased not
that the Japanese have surrendered but
hostilities have ceased all of the
Japanese delegates at the signing
recognized at once once it was
translated that the what he was saying
what it really meant and that was again
that this was a celebration not of
Japan's surrender humiliation but of a
new era a new era for Asia a new era for
Japan and a new set of relationships for
us and Japan partnership in the future
which is really what MacArthur's role as
then overseeing the occupation of Japan
really involved when the story doesn't
end there because five years less than
five years after the end of the war
North Korean forces invade South Korea
on the 25th of June 1950 and MacArthur
has putted the in the role of trying to
reverse this desperate situation and to
prevent catastrophe and the loss of the
entire Korean Peninsula to the
Communists and so he conceives this plan
this brilliant plan of an enterprise and
fibia slanting at Incheon which all of
the experts says it will not work this
is not gonna happen you understand
everything is against you in carrying
this kind of thing of the meteorological
conditions the the tides tipping is not
gonna succeed and he goes ahead and he
goes ahead and does it despite even
objections from the Joint Chiefs of
staff's he persuades them that he knows
what he's doing that destiny will not
let him fail at this endeavor and so in
September of 1950 he leads the landing
amphibious landing at Incheon and it
completely changes the reverses the
course of the war and enables the Allied
forces the UN forces not only to
recapture Seoul the capital of South
Korea but also to capture Pyongyang the
capital of North Korea and to bring the
possibility of the unification of Korea
into into into as close to reality as it
as it has ever been so that's the man
that's a hell of a record that's hell of
a resume when you think about it I lead
a war commander at general in three
world wars World War one and two and
Korea and the Cold War a man who's whose
military record is is one that involves
not only enormous bravery and courage
under fire but also includes one of the
most important strategic operations ever
conducted by an American military
commander the landing at Inchon and you
can include other of his decisions made
during the war in the Pacific as ways of
as also fitting into into the operations
of a true strategic genius I think in
the carrying out of his war if his war
record and if his war accomplishments so
I should be done right I mean that takes
care of the whole case but there's a
problem here and the problem is is that
when we look at Douglas MacArthur's
record in that way and we lay it out
decade by decade war by war it's hugely
impressive it's it's it's stellar so why
is Douglas MacArthur's reputation so
lousy why is it that for decades he's
been looked down upon
he's been derided been traduced been
subjected to any number of types of
attacks and of slurs on his character
even on his on his own on his own
physical bravery many stories for
example that he you know the the rumors
that go around about his escape from
Craig a door was a means by which you
know he was able to avoid you know the
possibility of abandoned his troops and
fled out of fear of physical danger the
idea promoted by a contemporary
historian by the way that in fact that
he bribed bribed the President of the
Philippines in order to made him pay a
bribe in order to escape from Corregidor
himself I've heard one story I was told
this when I was working in the MacArthur
archives in Norfolk Virginia that he
chose the place for the landing at Leyte
in the liberation of the Philippines at
Tacloban because his mistress had a
house there and that this was in fact
why he chose the landing Douglas
MacArthur didn't have a mistress it
never was a mistress it's a completely
made-up story and yet people make these
kinds of stories up all the time and
even that photograph that I started with
his landing at Leyte there even the
stories that in fact that was all staged
that that was rehearsed or even even
even done on and filmed on a safe beach
somewhere even before he arrived in the
Philippines and so on it's not true it's
not true it what the film showed and
what the photographs show is what really
happened that the the damn amphibious
vehicle got stuck on a sandbar and they
had to get off in water you know up over
up up to their hips and jump out
MacArthur had done it before and other
landings in the southwest Pacific too
was nothing new for him but it was but
given the fact that this was taking
place while the beach was still under
fire and we're snipers were still a
hundred yards away taking potshots at
anything that moved on the beach it was
again a story almost too good to be true
and I think that's all true of a lot of
MacArthur's career it's almost too good
to be true and I think that's one reason
why in many ways the efforts to
denigrate his career and to smear his
his character tend to stick because he
does seem to be almost too good to be
true as a figure so what I want to do is
I want to spend some time talking a
little bit about why I think Douglas
MacArthur has been treated as dis Curtis
Lee as he has and why that why that
stands out in many ways as a part of his
career compared to his other two other
generals in World War two I mean look at
patent patent gets a great movie right
with George C Scott and a fantastic
soundtrack with it too and George
Marshall you know who who's also you
know revered as a sort of demigod in
many ways as a general an Eisenhower
right who again treated with reverence
and with enormous respect even by
Hollywood I mean if anybody have seen
the Tom Selleck portrayal of Dwight
Eisenhower and the days leading up to
d-day it's a really it's a wonderful
movie by the way but it's it's a great
portrayal of
you know Eisenhower is being as being a
man to be admired a man dealing with
difficult situations and what does
MacArthur get he gets a movie he's
portrayed by Gregory Peck it's a
terrible movie if you've ever seen it
it's based on the William Manchester
book which has enormous biography which
is enormous flaws in many problems in
fact one of the reasons I wrote the book
was because I got impatient with the
Manchester book and his treatment of
MacArthur especially in the later years
here and the soundtrack is hideous as
well just just not up - not up to
standards so why why is all this
happening what I think are some answers
for this the first is is that he is a
man who lived on the edge of the
unconventional in everything that he did
everything he did was a slap in the face
to the commonplace and to the standard
way of operating including in his own in
his own military service and when we
think of him there he is with his
trademark pipe right and his and the hat
with the gold braid which he had
designed himself designed himself while
he was Field Marshal of the Philippine
Philippine land forces if we actually
turned the clock back about thirty years
to 1914 when he was a part of the
landing army landings at Veracruz he's
already there that's him that's him
he's got the even got the corncob pipe
at this point as a young lieutenant and
there he is with his you know his his
his letter sweater from from West Point
and his suspenders and the and the tie
around his neck and so on that is not
standard US Army uniform just want to
let you know and it's at the same time
it's by the way at that same expedition
then he's there that he performs one of
his most amazing feats and exploits of
bravery venturing into an enemy
territory in order to make a
reconnaissance about there about the
railroad stock that the Mexican army had
on hand that had to be blown up
that was clearly recommended for a Medal
of Honor there was no
doubt about it but there's also no doubt
that this guy this kid is someone who is
not going to get a Medal of Honor you
know not when he act like this not when
you behave like that even now if you're
Arthur MacArthur's son still still there
are limits to what we're gonna put up
with and there was just something about
Douglas MacArthur that graded on
conventional Minds and the standard
standard issue standard issue military
mind and that never changed that was
going to be true in World War one for
example - we're again there he is by the
way a second figure on the left right in
combat in going over the top in trench
warfare he never wore a helmet no one
could get him to wear a helmet he was
always wearing that strange forage cap
of his which was actually army
regulation cap from which he had pulled
out the iron brace from inside the one
that keeps it erect so it had that sort
of crushed flattened look that went with
it probably picked that up from some of
the Royal Flying Corps officers who had
the same kind of sort of that kind of
sort of a casual dashing look to it at
the same time a young a American aviator
by the name of Billy Mitchell came by to
see him and saw the cap and said I want
one of those too so he pulled out his
his the the iron brace from his cap as
well and it became again sort of the
standard look for our army aviator 'he's
right through to world war ii if you
look at that hat and associated with
right the cockpit on a b-17 for example
you've got yourself a scene from 12
o'clock high that's where that that's
where that hat and that's where that
costume came through from Billy Mitchell
via from Douglas MacArthur ability the
ability Billy Mitchell but everything
about him in that he's a staff officer
but he goes over the top goes over the
top with the regular troops because he
says he needs to see what's really
happening on the ground he can't learn
what's really taking place in the
fighting and and the terrain if he's
gonna stay back at headquarters he's got
to be in the front run but doesn't wear
a helmet
doesn't carry a weapon no sidearm
couldn't be Bobby so what do I want
something like that just get in the way
here it doesn't carry a gas mask bag
either and in fact he's gonna be very
badly gassed during the fighting during
the fighting in the Argonne forest as a
result of that pays for that pays for
that little quirk of his but this is the
Douglas MacArthur who evolved this is
one who is constantly defying the
standard-issue view of how he should act
and how he should behave under all
circumstances and the iconic Douglas
MacArthur that we know from World War
two and from Korea is really a man who
is the who is the who's the product of
that unconventionality the second reason
I think why MacArthur is reputation is
not perhaps as high as it is and it's
not unexpected given the fact that he is
someone who defies the conventional and
everything else is the fact that he
never hesitates to tell superiors what
he really thinks of them and this is
going to get you in trouble by the way
including in institutions like the
United States Army if you do that but
again it's an irrepressible part of
MacArthur's ways of doing things
starting with General Pershing during
World War one and then continuing on
when he becomes chief of staff for the
US Army under theater under Franklin
Roosevelt and you have this picture of
them here in this sort of looking very
chummy and sharing a jovial moment there
weren't a lot of those between Roosevelt
and and MacArthur MacArthur all through
the 1920s and 1930s was absolutely
convinced that the United States
military budget had been cut too much
that it was had been sliced to the bone
and then some and he has constant
battles both with Congress and with the
White House about ways in which to raise
the raise the raised army army budgets
and the authorizations for funds after
one particularly bruising
confrontation with Roosevelt in the
White House in fact MacArthur when he
stepped out onto the onto the White
House steps threw up the tension had
been so bad that he basically lost it
afterwards in the course of it he lost
more battles than he won but the the
sort of bruising contests that he was
engaged in with regard with regard to
Franklin Roosevelt was one of the
reasons it's not the primaries and one
of the reasons why Roosevelt felt free
to call him one of the most dangerous
man in America along with Huey Long and
it was also one reason why Roosevelt
encouraged encouraged MacArthur to take
up the post of commander-in-chief of
Philippine forces and to go to the
Philippines and resign his commission in
the US Army in order to take up take up
that post in the country that his father
Arthur MacArthur had helped to liberate
and to restructure after the after the
spanish-american war and in which he had
served for many years as a young officer
and then as and then as a Major General
that kind of confrontation with
superiors would continue during World
War two where he and Roosevelt again had
had constant bruising battles over the
course of the war about whether the war
should be focused on Europe as opposed
to being focused in Asia contests about
what part of the Pacific War it should
be focused on as well because the Navy
had pushing on that you can see on the
right there Admiral Nimitz had their own
conception of how to win the war in the
Pacific and the direction in which US
forces in the u.s. u.s. resources should
be committed and MacArthur had very
different ideas about the way in which
the war should be conducted that it
should be one that conducted through the
southwest Pacific to final liberation of
the Philippines and then use the
Philippines as a spring
as a springboard for the invasion of
Japan whereas Nimitz in the Air Force
and the Navy saw a push through the
Central Pacific that would finish up in
in Formosa Taiwan and then that would
become the base for eventual invasion of
Japan in the end MacArthur never won his
contest with Nimitz but he was able to
ensure that both thrusts into the
Pacific received equal time or close to
equal time an equal commitment and that
when the when the two arms of US effort
in the Pacific met that he would assume
supreme command of the forces as they
assembled together for the final four
the final approach on Japan so you see
that the MacArthur the Douglas MacArthur
who would ultimately confront to Harry
Truman over the conduct of the war in
Korea I'm gonna sailed it more about
that in detail in a little bit that that
Douglas MacArthur is one who had already
been schooled in this approach to
dealing with superiors and that is is
that if you know your right tell them so
and if you know their wrong then
definitely tell them so whether it's a
whether it's a general or whether it's a
president you have the privilege and the
responsibility to point out their
mistakes and to explain to and to tell
them that why you were wrong
why you are right and why they are wrong
and that ultimate confrontation them in
this in the in February of 1951 between
Truman and MacArthur has this long
build-up a long pattern of behavior on
the part of MacArthur that has as I said
what's amazing is when you think about
someone who has takes that kind of
truculent attitude with regard to his
bosses and its superiors it's amazing he
had the career he did under those
circumstances I think it's proof of the
degree to which the
to which even those who thoroughly
disliked Douglas MacArthur had to
respect him if not actually fear him and
were able to give him the promotions and
give him the responsibilities of command
that they knew really against their will
that he was capable of fulfilling now
that landing at Inchon the landing in
incheon that was again the final result
of confrontation with the White House
with Truman's senior advisors with the
Joint Chiefs of Staff here really brings
us then to where Douglas MacArthur's
ability to defy criticism and to prevail
really reached it's reached his height
because of the landing of introns that
led to the occupation the occupation of
Seoul and then to the liberation of
Pyongyang were really the result of that
final strategic move I just used I just
put this slide up there because I love
it it doesn't really have any business
doing this but it's it's it's a
wonderful photograph of these of this
Guatemalans in in the process of
retaking sole that is an action
photograph let me tell you these guys
looking for looking for North Korean
snipers as they're going through the
operations to to free soul from the
communists love that picture
now I'll come to the third reason why
Douglas MacArthur I think has been
treated badly by historians and by
posterity particularly posterity on the
left side of the political aisle and
that is his fierce anti-communism no
doubt about that this is he played a big
role in in seeing Douglas MacArthur in a
very different light than other military
figures of the 20th century who have not
been so straightened it have not been so
forthright in their detestation of
communism and all of its works it was
that hatred of communism for example
that led him to take the very strong
line with regard to the Bonus Army
marchers when they descended on
Washington in 1932 and his decision that
they would simply not be allowed to stay
and they had to go in large part because
he feared as I explained in the book
with some justification that the Bonus
Army marchers were actually had been
infiltrated by elements of the Communist
Party of the United States of America
who saw that Occulus mass occupation of
the national of the nation's capital as
a prelude to possible revolution
certainly to large-scale street violence
not just in Washington but around the
country
and so it was for this reason that rose
that MacArthur believed that even though
the Barna smart bonus marchers caused
may possibly have been just that their
methods were unjust and wrong and that
they therefore had to be forced out of
their camps that they had pitched
pitched on the on the National Mall now
it has to be said and I know you read my
book you'll get the details about this
that the violence that was involved the
shooting and killing of bonus marchers
and so on was not by MacArthur or by his
troops by the DC police they were if any
force was really out of control in that
in the bonus march confrontation there
was the DC police and was left - he was
left in MacArthur and the army to pick
up the pieces from from the front
mess that and the debacle that they had
caused but it was a violent
confrontation it was one that ruined the
reputation of the Hoover administration
who had the White House had given the
final order to evict the Bonus Army
marchers and it almost certainly is was
the final straw for finishing off
Hoover's any chance of who was being
reelected in 1932 not just the
depression but also the debacle of the
bonus march and the way in which it was
the way it was put out but MacArthur's
anti-communist statements regarded the
bonus march sure would come to haunt him
in the leftist press and they would they
very quickly made him the key villain in
the whole story of the bonus march there
were even stories that circulated in in
the Daily Worker of all places the
Communist daily organ that MacArthur had
led the charge against the bonus the
unarmed two bonus marchers on a white
horse here in this marvelous cavalry
charge all made up of course there was
no truth to it whatsoever but it made
him an easy target and in a in a
favorite target for the leftist press
that was going to get worse of course
after his dismissal by to Harry Truman
in 1951 because of their disagreements
on the policy in the conduct of the war
in Korea and his speech to the joint
session of Congress when he returned to
the United States to rapturous crowds of
millions of people in every city that he
and his wife stopped in on the way back
back to on their way to Washington and
that speech to the joint session of
Congress the famous wand that ends old
soldiers never die
that speech contained a strong
anti-communist message and strong made
it clear that the Truman
administration's policy was inadequate
for keeping the forces of communism from
being on the march in Asia and again it
also helped to make them
Arthur a favorite target on liberal
press and liberal media and defenders of
Truman as being someone whose dismissal
whose dismissal was not just a matter of
result of disagreements over policy in
how to conduct war in Korea but was had
been a gross violation of the separation
between military and civilian command of
the Armed Forces here almost to the
point of treating MacArthur's if he had
almost staged a kind of coup against the
government by his refusal and by his
public pronouncements about the Truman
policy on the war in Korea the
Republican Congress that took up the
investigation into MacArthur's firing
probably didn't help the case very much
because they instead of concentrating
their efforts on the merits or the
demerits for MacArthur's dismissal see
were obsessed with the idea that there
were secret communists in the Truman
White House who had engineered this
thing at the best of Moscow there simply
was no evidence to support such claims
but it did a lot to sort of dissipate
the energies and the focus of those
hearings on MacArthur's dismissal and
again help to make the Truman forces in
those supporters seem more right than
wrong in the course of the discussion
and that just that fact then led to the
other major factor in the turning of the
nation's view about Douglas MacArthur
because it became an industry especially
for historians linked to Democrat Party
and to the Truman administration people
like Arthur Schlessinger for example to
suggest that what they saw as
MacArthur's disastrous policy in Korea
which had led to his dismissal is the
charge that that had a long history of
military failures stretching all the way
back to the Philippines when he had been
caught flat-footed by the Japanese
attack on December 7th time to occur at
the same time as the attack on Pearl
Harbor
and then a series of major mistakes by
MacArthur had led to the failure and the
collapse of American resistance in the
Philippines of a of a disgraceful
episode in Americans military history
which MacArthur had fled from by
escaping from color egged or overlooking
the fact that MacArthur had as I
explained in my book had quite set for
himself the idea that he was going to
die at Corregidor died with the rest of
his troops and that and that it was
Roosevelt's order did he leave the
Philippines and go to Australia to
assume command of American forces to
relieve the Philippines it was that
direct order which he at the end decided
he could not disobey and that led him to
lead himself and his family and his
staff to to leave the to leave the
island fortress and of course what we
what's easy to forget is is that the
missteps and the failures that had taken
place in the Philippines were we're also
then matched from the point of view
liberal joins by what had happened in
the Korea where it was argued MacArthur
had failed to understand the dangers
that were be run by having US forces
advance as far north as the Yalu River
and that China the Communist China then
in reaction to that American thrust then
poured troops across the border
catching MacArthur's forces by surprise
and triggering a massive panicked
retreat to the south to the to the far
southern end of the peninsula and
leading to such military disasters as
the as the entrapment a truce in at the
at the reservoir there and the the long
bloody retreat from out of North Korea
into the South here all of this he get
more examples historians and biographers
would claim and and critics would claim
just one more example of MacArthur's
flawed military judgment and inability
to learn from his own mistakes
of course what this overlooked was
number one in the case of the
Philippines that MacArthur did actually
get to the Philippines did actually
muster together American forces and
Australian forces to begin the process
of pushing the Japanese out of the South
Pacific starting in New Guinea and that
MacArthur what MacArthur was able to do
was to do this by pressing forward with
a new way of thinking about military
warfare and that was is what we would
call today combined arms operations
involving forces at sea forces at land
and forces in the air a series of
surprise and fibia slán dings backed by
airpower
that would enable the u.s. to turn what
would seem to be an insuperable obstacle
to two to coherent military operations
is vast archipelago spread out across
all of these the this vast stretch of
ocean and to turn what would seem to be
a disadvantage for u.s. forces into an
advantage the new could strike where the
Japanese least expected it and could
overwhelm the Japanese Garrison's and
Islands one by one a strategy that
became known as island hopping and in
the process by doing so McArthur not
only found a way in which he could
defeat the Japanese piecemeal in ways
that they could not keep up with and
could not could not follow or reinforce
their positions but at the same time he
found a way in which to save American
lives did the amphibious landings
catching the enemies with with in the
rear when they least expected it was
actually a way in which you kept
casualties down compared to the full
frontal assaults at places like Terra
and later at Iwo Jima and then later at
Okinawa and we have to say one of the
reasons why MacArthur was so well liked
by his troops and by his junior officers
was he kept him alive at a time when
many of their fellow Marines or when
either many army fellow army officers
and soldiers were being killed in large
numbers in the Central Pacific campaigns
here highly successful operational
strategy that also turned into one that
could be used to reduce American
casualties while accelerating Japanese
ones and then of course that also set
the stage that campaign in the Pacific
and the route that he had taken in order
to get there with the liberation of the
Philippines first and foremost in his
mind also set the stage for the next
stage which was the occupation and
liberation of Japan for giving Japan a
new reason for life as a civilized
community and this photograph the
photograph of MacArthur in his basically
army fatigues the uniform he always wore
by the way the uniform he always wore
without decorations with just the mark
just the insignia of his rank standing
next to the Emperor Hirohito a god to
his people before and during the war
sent shockwaves across Japan when that
photograph appeared it was as shocking
as it would be for to see an American
president standing next to a Martian
which is in effect what the Americans
were from the point of view of the
Japanese so remote was their culture so
remote was their country and values here
it was a real signal that a new era has
come for better or for worse for Japan
and you better get used to it because
the emperor has already gotten used to
it and has realized this is the new
existence this is the new Japan at which
I'm going to be part and within two
years the Japanese people came to
realize that MacArthur far from being a
conqueror had was in fact a liberator
that he was a man who had brought a new
era to Japan and a new era for Asia as a
whole in the process and when you go to
Tokyo you go to the Daiichi Insurance
Building which is where he was
headquartered the old insurance building
is gone of course it's the modern one
they have up in the floor they have
preserved they have reconstructed
MacArthur's office they're really a
tribute to a figure who is I would say
much more hero much more hero in Japan
than he is here really in many ways just
as he is as much more of a hero in Korea
because of his liberation of soul during
the Korean War than he is here as well
it's ironic it's ironic American general
who celebrated more by foreigners to
appreciate what he did that he his by
Americans we also have to say about him
too is that in those years we come to
realize that the person who really made
all of this possible for MacArthur who
really held him together after all those
years of strife and of end of tension
was his wife Jean MacArthur amazing
woman from Murfreesboro Tennessee his
second wife and the one with whom he
finally found domestic peace and
domestic support all through his career
all through his career he is I think one
of the key factors in how MacArthur was
able to function with that degree of
confidence and skill through all that
say all the ups and downs of the career
that went with it and when I wrote the
biography I had the privilege of being
the first historian to use her oral
biography in the archives as part of as
part of the book that was new material
brand-new unreleased material which I
was able to incorporate into the
biography and it was it was a real
privilege to be able to work through
that material and to integrate it into
it now when I fighters trying to say a
final word about the other aspect of
Douglas MacArthur that makes him I think
also unique among American generals
perhaps and also certainly among
American political figures and that was
the degree of vision that he brought to
his work and to his value if he thought
of himself not simply as a general in
military terms but generals in the in
the broadest strategic terms at the same
time here and what I have to say is is
that in many ways MacArthur when we look
at his career we look at the way in
which he envisioned himself acting on
the world stage which he became
accustomed to at a very young age at a
very young age with his experience
during the First World War and being
after that in many ways he was a person
who saw the future more clearly than he
saw the present and that's a quality I
think that we that historians can come
to recognize that perhaps sometimes
escapes contemporaries and I think the
best
example of this in many ways is the way
in which he came to understand the
forces at work in dynamics and world
politics there were at work in the
Korean War that for the for that for
Truman and his policymakers that the
Korean War was very much seen through
the prism of the conflict between the
free world and the communism not so
that's surprisingly not surprisingly
that's absolutely absolutely part of
part of the story there's no doubt about
that but MacArthur saw in a slightly
different regard and it was regard that
he gave he supplied to general Marshall
when Marshall in the fall of 1950 when
it became clear the Chinese were now
pouring across the border it had entered
into this conflict when when Marshall
wrote to him and sort of said what do
you think the Chinese are up to
and so MacArthur told him in a in a in a
cable a cable which I found in the
MacArthur archives it's not been
published before now which I talked
about in the book and here's what he
says about the Chinese entrance into the
war in Korea he says there are tivities
in Korea throughout have been offensive
never defensive blows away the whole
argument that the reason the Chinese had
entered the conflict was because the
Americans got too close to the Yellow
River and now by the way subsequently
looking through Chinese archives we now
that this is true Mao was preparing for
this war at the moment the very first
American troops arrived in the Korean
Peninsula in August of 1950 he was ready
to go to war already because he saw this
as a huge opportunity for China and for
what China was going to accomplish said
what is on display in Korea Carr Thoreau
is a Chinese nationalism of increasingly
dominant aggressive tendencies that was
spawned fifty years before during the
Boxer Rebellion and has been brought to
its greatest fruition under the present
Mao regime the result he said has been
the creation of a new and dominant power
in Asia which for its own purposes is
allied with the Soviet Union but which
in its own concepts and methods
has become increasingly and aggressively
imperialistic with a lust for expansion
and for increased power he said it's
true that China's aims are now currently
aligned with that of the Soviet Union
but the aggression shown in Korea as
well as Indochina and Tibet says that
Peking was following its own line of
expansive expansionist conquest on the
one hand it showed that Chinese were not
automatically Soviet satellites as so
many in the true administration had
assumed on the other MacArthur wrote
when they reach the full potential
nasarah eteri potential i dread to think
what may happen now I don't think you
can find anyone in American politics
anywhere in 1950 who would be able to
see with such prescience the conflict in
which we live today and be aware of how
where it was coming in how it was coming
about here and in fact when we think
about it in that light we can see that
even now today China's first island
chain strategy that it is developed as a
means by which to break out from the
Eurasian landmass and to become a
dominant player in world politics the
first island chain that we can see here
extending from Japan all the way down to
the northern Borneo and the Philippines
the second island chain that extends out
extending out as far as Guam to New
Guinea the whole idea of the island
chain strategy they stole from MacArthur
he was the one who developed that during
during during the during the Korean War
that the way in which to contain China
was by a strong US presence in a string
of bases that would hold together what
he called the first island chain and
what the Chinese simply did was to steal
MacArthur's terminology in his strategy
and turn it inside out instead of the
first island chain
being away English to him China in
contained it becomes a way for China to
break out and to become the dominant
dominant power in the region in the area
here and get that same strategy those
elements that have gone on to the the
rise of contemporary China the rise of a
China which envisions itself not only is
a great land power but now is a great
maritime power with a navy able to rival
that of Douglas that of the United
States Navy ready to displace American
presence not just in the South China Sea
in the East China Sea but across the
Pacific here and even the rise of China
as a major technological and high-tech
power how it envisions itself is a power
in terms of the developments of
artificial intelligence of becoming the
world's leading AI driven regime country
by 2025 as part of their overall plans
their plans in quantum technology and
quantum competing which I know a lot
about these days as a matter of fact all
of these things are in effect previewed
and predicted in MacArthur's memo from
October of nineteen of tober of 1950
here and I think that strategic vision
that ability to contain to encapsulate
and understand that strategic vision
here is I think what puts MacArthur in a
class by himself here and just as I
think MacArthur clearly saw the forces
at work the correlation of forces at
work in the conflict in Korea I think he
is a figure who if he were with us today
here today would understand the
correlations of forces at work today in
terms of the competition between the US
and the China I think we miss him more
than we realize and we miss his vision
perhaps more than we can contemplate but
the historical record is clear the man
stands above the critics and above the
detractors his record stands I think as
one which reaches in terms of its global
reach surpasses that of any other I'm
american-statesman let alone American
general and I think it's one why he very
much believes in this belongs in this
select company of great American
generals and leaders that we've been
talking about all week I'm actually done
so we're all set to go
thank you
so we want to clear some time for some
questions and I'm happy to feel them I
think what you have to do is they they
want you to go up to the to the people
holding the students holding a
microphone and then you can then you can
shoot away fire away
thank you dr. Herman just a quick
announcement dr. Herman will be signing
a copy of his book Douglas MacArthur
American warrior in the sterile Lobby
immediately following the lecture and we
now have time for a few questions so if
you please step forward I'm not gonna
leave you with this slide by the way
let's let's get the man himself up there
shall we much better much better good
afternoon sir
thank you very much for your time coming
out here to Hillsdale today I brightly
enjoyed your lecture
thank you I did have a question about a
comment made regarding the William
Manchester biography on an American
Caesar Manchester in this book
specifically makes a comment about his
relationship with the Marine Corps
during the Pacific campaign and correct
me if I'm wrong on the account of a
leave Manchester makes the comment that
MacArthur omitted Marines from Unit
Citations
that were under his command during the
Pacific campaign specifically making the
comment and I quote they had their Bello
would would you be able to confirm or
debunk if there's any truth in that and
provide any further comment on his
relationship with the Marines no I don't
think that that's there's any kind of
great accuracy to that at all I think
that the the difficulties with the
Marines that he had and they carried out
a number of important and really quite
brutal operations particularly acklie
Cape Gloucester really had to do with
disagreements between MacArthur and the
marine commanders he's an army guy what
do you want you know the US Army was
that was the was his was it was his
service he was in my his mind the
service to be supported the Marines were
from that point of view of course not as
important in the overall story I think
the other problem that he had with the
Marines too is that is that so much of
the resources that he did he believed he
should have had from the Marine Corps
was all diverted into
the Central Pacific and was and was and
was sent away there I also don't
necessarily trust Manchester's account
of this you know Manchester himself was
the US Marine so I'm sorry I think he
carries a certain amount of bias in that
regard in terms of in terms of the
development between it look look you
just saw my picture of the man he's
gonna have abrasive relations with
everyone he had if you were to turn to
the accounts as I do in my biography of
Australian commanders in dealing with
him - they were very very very very
friction bound in the dealings within
the Australians - often complained about
the fact that McArthur didn't took away
their autonomy threw them away in in in
in in in sideshow operations didn't get
their share of decorations and so on
it's interesting how that constantly
pops up in the case of in the case of
MacArthur that there's so much
controversy surrounding the issues about
decorations and things like that but the
the McArthur Manchester biography that's
one of the reasons why I wanted to
replace it and it felt into supplanted
the other reasons I think the chapters
that he has on the Korean War there are
are really inadequate as well as totally
misguided there's a reason for that by
the way and that is is that the the
masterful biography the biography of
MacArthur the three vol 1 by D Clayton
James the third volume which was on
Korea hadn't been finished by the time
Manchester got started on his biography
wasn't done so he didn't have that to
lean on in terms of his discussion about
documentation and about the overall the
overall course of the war he was sort of
left to his own devices and I'm afraid
his own devices were not really not
really adequate to the job I mean it
came to writing about MacArthur just my
view
sure what else we have time for one more
question
just one more can we get how about if we
put it okay time for two more okay about
that give another time
yeah please I was interested in your
comment about his ability to see into
the future
yeah my father flew b-29s in the Pacific
during World War two as a member of the
first total reconnaissance squadron and
he always told me that he thought
MacArthur had great foresight because at
the end of the war before they were
allowed to come home they were ordered
to fly mapping grids over all of Korea
to map all of Korea and I was wondering
if you would comment on whether you
thought even at that point in time that
MacArthur was foreseeing that there was
going to be great trouble there because
that's what my father always thought
well that's very interesting
I don't know I I couldn't tell you if
that orders were coming directly from
MacArthur himself you do understand that
Korea was outside of his perimeter of
responsibility when he was supreme
commander and then afterwards as head of
the Allied occupation forces in in Japan
the State Department was in charge most
people don't realize that State
Department was in charge of post-war
Korea not MacArthur or the US Army there
was a military mission there but it was
subordinate to the State Department's
responsibility so in many ways I think
history I'll tell you this and this
perhaps is collateral for your father's
theory if MacArthur had been placed in
command of Korea as well as Japan if
they'd have been in curtain been
incorporated into his area of
responsibilities as AOR maybe the Korean
War might never have happened
he might may it's quite possible that he
may have been able to take steps that
would have made a North Korean attack
less likely and certainly less
devastating than an action
was on Okinawa yeah yeah there he would
have been in MacArthur's ail AOR there's
no doubt about that please yes sir I was
wondering if you could talk on the
perceived instability by the Joint
Chiefs of Staff in Washington on
MacArthur towards the end of the Korean
War and on top of that his some
interviews that he gave after the
Warrens like in the mid-1950s about how
how he claimed his plan was to be back
China by using up to 30 to 50 nuclear
weapons in the actual conflict that
proceeded in China and some weird talk
that he gave about possibly
contaminating the land area to prevent
the ease of movement by the Chinese army
and I was wondering if you could talk
about that kind of mentality because I
think that's why a lot of people look
pretty unfavorably on him towards the
end of his career yeah I think there's
also a lot of misunderstanding
surrounding that so I'm glad you asked
the questions I can somewhat set the
record straight on that the issue of the
use of nuclear weapons in the Korean
Conflict we don't really know what
MacArthur's plan was while he was
commander of UN forces he had put that
on the table as an option but it was an
option that already existed and which
the chief of the the Joint Chiefs of
Staff had already prepared for everyone
understood that nuclear weapons were a
devastating weapon the idea of using
nuclear weapons to attack Chinese cities
had absolutely no appeal for MacArthur
what was the point the point of it was
that you would use nuclear weapons to
create a a I'm going to use the French
Accord on sunnydale right a barrier
impenetrable barrier in which Chinese
reinforcements for their forces in Korea
could not get through that was part of
standard Joint Chiefs doctrine everybody
had talked about this as a possibility
and the use of this and MacArthur
thought that this was a this could
possibly be an option in that conflict
and the Joint Chiefs agreed one of the
declassified documents that I got to see
was one that involved the actual flying
out
of components for an atomic bomb - teen
yang before MacArthur was fired for the
that very possibility of the use of the
use of nuclear weapons against against
China you know five years after
Hiroshima and Nagasaki of an event which
was seen of having decisively knocked
Japan out of the war it seemed to be not
the great horrific weapon that it's come
to be in modern imaginations in 1950 it
seems a decisive weapon of war so you
contemplated that you contemplated that
as a battlefield theater theater theater
weapon nothing unusual about that
so MacArthur's firing it wasn't for
threatening to use nuclear weapons
everybody accepted that was that would
have been fair game it wasn't really
even for any for disagreeing disobeying
orders anything like that it was for a
letter that he had sent to the
Republican Speaker of the House Joe
Martin complaining about the failure of
the Truman administration to fully
support his policy in Korea which was to
push the Chinese back to the border - to
push them out of North Korea altogether
Martin read the letter without
MacArthur's knowledge in the on the
floor floor of the house and for
MacArthur news advisors that was the
last straw he had already made
statements pronouncements to the press
talking complaining bitterly about the
way the Truman administration had held
it back and had and it stayed his hand
in operations in Korea and so the
feeling was is that this constituted a
form of insubordination that they were
simply we're not going to tolerate and
so he was gone was it insubordination I
conclude in the book that it was and I
conclude in the book in the final
analysis that probably MacArthur
deserved to be fired I think he knew he
was going to be fired that's one of the
reasons while he wrote the letter to
Martin he knew it was coming but had
nothing to do with nuclear weapons
nothing to do with quote widening the
war in that sense it had to do with
instead of the fear that
a renewed push to the Chinese border
would simply bring more Chinese troops
into the conflict I don't know if that's
actually true the Chinese were fully
committed into the war already and
MacArthur and ridgeway's forces had
devastated the Chinese forces perhaps as
much as a million Chinese volunteers
volunteers
Chinese troops had been killed pushing
back up through South Korea up to the
38th parallel it had been a massive
slaughter Mao really didn't have the
kinds of effective reserves to commit to
a conflict of this kind here as well
Ridgeway agreed by the way with
MacArthur Ridgeway agreed with MacArthur
that was how he envisioned the campaign
continuing a push all the way up beyond
the 38th parallel up up to the up to the
to the Chinese North Korean border
reunify the peninsula that was his view
and the true administrators that's not
gonna happen our allies won't support it
we're stopping at 38th parallel
ridgway's say that's fine but Ridgeway
never gets you know reputation for being
war monger quite the opposite he is seen
wrongly as the man who picked up the
pieces that MacArthur had left on the
ground after the Chinese attack here I
got a lot more to say about this but
we've got more questions actually we
don't have time for any more questions
but please give a round of applause for
dr. Berman thank you so much
you